[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM WANG: It's common these days
for voters to feel frustrated.
To feel as if legislators
aren't paying attention
to them, whether it's the
Flint water crisis in Michigan
or partisan polarization or
other ways in which legislators
seem to not heed their
constituents’ opinions.
Legislative seats nationwide
are less competitive
than they used to be.
And one big reason
why is gerrymandering.
Voters have chosen
to arrange themselves
in cities and towns
in rural areas,
and then legislators
take that natural pattern
and draw the lines as they
like to suit themselves.
A major problem is
partisan gerrymandering,
drawing a whole pattern
of districts to suit
one whole political party.
Redistricting happens
every 10 years.
This leads to a
situation in which
close to 100 seats in Congress
are less competitive than they
would be otherwise.
Intuitively we think
about gerrymandering
as centering around weird
shaped boundaries, right?
Strangely shaped
boundaries that are
crooked that have funny
bumps and valleys and so on.
It turns out that's
not such a great way
to define a gerrymander.
Because voters tend to live in
communities of like mindedness,
imagine a city that
is mostly Democrats
and imagine it surrounded
by a community of voters
who are mostly Republicans
distributed over space.
It is possible to
creatively draw lines
where we can pack the
Democrats in one district,
for instance, by
drawing a boundary
that encompasses
most of the Democrats
in a single nicely
circularly shaped district,
and then distributing
the remaining Democrats
over remaining districts
so that in the end
the Republicans get an
overwhelming advantage.
You can take the same
map and do the opposite.
You can take this nice cluster
of voters in the center
and now take wedges
out of that center city
and now create pie slices, and
the first bite of each pizza
slice will then be just
enough to make that slice
a secure win for Democrats.
Therefore it's
possible to draw lines
to make it either running
the table for Republicans
or running the
table for Democrats,
depending on what
legislators want.
So what's left is to come
up with some standard
where gerrymandering
can be defined
without reference to maps.
And it turns out there
is a tool available.
The idea is to invoke the
idea of partisan symmetry.
If one side has 75, 80 percent
of the vote in district
after district, that
side has been packed.
When one side wins
in landslides,
but the other side's
wins are closer,
the question arises,
did this overall pattern
occur incidentally as if by
chance or by nonpartisan means?
If not, then we would conclude
that one side's voters
were packed more than the
others as if on purpose.
It turns out this is the
easiest thing that you can test.
In all the sciences
and all of engineering,
the most widely used
test is something
called Student's T-test.
And it was made possible
by this guy William Gosset.
Gosset lived in the
early 20th century.
He was chief experimental
brewer of the Guinness Company
in Ireland.
Gosset had this problem of how
to tell if whether hops quality
was good.
And he was very
pleased about this.
And he said OK, I would
like to publish this.
And his lab notebook said
student’s laboratory notebook.
And he had a bit of
a sense of humor,
and he said, oh I'm a student.
And so to this day it's
called Student's T-test.
The T-test compares
two averages.
Here the two averages
are of the winning vote
share in Democratic districts
and the winning vote
share in Republican districts.
The T-test asks whether two
averages are different enough
that they are unlikely to
have arisen incidentally
from nonpartisan mechanisms.
For example,
redistricters want to draw
straight-ish boundaries.
They want to honor
communities of interest.
They want to follow other
rules that are set down in law.
And for those reasons,
averages can sometimes
be a little bit
different, advantaging
one side or the other side.
What the T-test asks is,
is that difference so large
that it could not have
arisen incidentally?
And if that's the
case, then what we have
is a likely gerrymander.
A great example of
partisan asymmetry
that can be detected using
the T-test is North Carolina.
2010 was a wave election
for the Republicans.
And with their new control
over the redistricting process,
they created an
advantage for themselves.
It was a perfect inversion of
what had happened previously.
Democrats ended up with
four congressional districts
and Republicans ended up with
nine congressional districts,
despite the fact that
Democratic candidates won
more votes that year.
This pattern was repeated
in 2014 and 2016.
And in each case, the vote
was reasonably closely split,
but in each case, the Democrats
won more lopsided wins.
And the T-test tells
us that this difference
between Democratic wins
and Republican wins
could not have arisen by chance.
There is overwhelming
public opinion
against gerrymandering
and a general sense
that it ought to be addressed.
And there are two ways.
One is through courts and
the other is by activists.
Courts could say we will define
gerrymandering as violation
of partisan symmetry.
Are the two parties being
treated fairly and equally?
And if they're not, then
there's partisan asymmetry.
And the Supreme Court has
expressed some willingness
to do that.
Another route is for activists.
Voters have started to
pass fair districting laws.
The risk is that they
may leave loopholes
by not thinking ahead and
realizing that in fact there
is still the possibility
of partisan asymmetry,
so writing into
the law something
like a simple statistical
test like the T-test would
close that last loophole.
Here's an opportunity to
make the democratic process
work a little bit better.
If this effort succeeds, what
we're going to end up with
is a situation that the
founders envisioned.
The voters pick their
legislators and not
the other way around.